we got uh elon musk is bullying bernie
sanders duncan on bernie sand
and threatening the stockholders too you
know what
okay
okay ready
this is a tweet i forget who the [ __ ]
said it but it wasn't this is not my
idea uh so i'm not going to take credit
for this and if you know who tweeted
this just give them credit for it my bad
i don't recall but um
there's a guy tweeted this thing he
basically was talking about china and he
goes uh what
uh germany did wrong what hitler did
wrong is he didn't make the world
reliant on the german economy before
world war ii that's the only thing you
did wrong
yeah is that what you're saying yeah
yeah continue
the only
issue the only error in judgment
hitler's judgment yeah no i guess what
he's saying is like in terms of like
you're trying to eradicate the jews he
goes it would have been easier if you
made the whole world reliant on the
german uh
uh the german economy because then
they'd look the other way in the same
way he goes this is what china did china
made the whole world reliant on the
chinese economy or basically chinese
goods so they so now everybody looks the
other way when they want to throw all
the muslims in a concentration camp when
they want to just say hey taiwan is
about to be china hong kong is about to
be china when they want to expand
throughout asia we look the other way
because like well i don't want to [ __ ]
up my [ __ ] yeah like you as an american
got to start asking yourself like do we
really care about taiwan like yeah do we
really care about hong kong how much do
we really care about the south asian
pacific yeah or whatever the [ __ ] they
keep trying to build islands in or do
whatever is in a way america also do the
same thing 100 yeah we we i'm sure we're
the masters of it yeah um but why we
hold ourselves accountable
sell out canadian no um
and i brought this up in regards to elon
musk
if you owned tesla
elon can say whatever he was
before i owned tesla i was very critical
of eli
yeah i bought tesla and now i'm like
bernie suck dicks bro
why are you talking about my mans yeah
don't let him sell more to stock my [ __ ]
goes down when he sells the stuff that's
why i don't understand the criticism
people were like oh why do you uh why do
you defend billionaires like people be
like why the billionaires don't care
about you what is a billionaire ever
done for you and you're like
maybe a thousand makes me money
yes yeah a little 100 if i'm investing
that billionaire's company if i'm
invested in amazon google apple all
these [ __ ] they've done stuff
for me yeah help me fight inflation
right they care
they they went public they went on a
stock market yes it's a public offering
we are the public
they do a lot for us we like it they
send our kids to college right this is
our kids college fund this is our work
they help us retire if you're invested
if you're invested but you know what
anybody could invest it's not like they
got a moat around the investment well
you have to spend money
that's true
stop buying jordans jordan's
testimony tesla this is more expensive
bro say what tesla wasn't always
expensive even if it's not buy buy a
fraction of a share
can you do that with a share i don't
think i think it's not it's not bitcoin
literally the company that is on this
podcast
public public says you can buy fractions
of a share
oh all right i think you can alright
well i'm a dumbass guys i don't know all
i'm saying is
shits go out so now what he did is he
made
the american public dependent on his
success not completely dependent but we
want him to win because if he wins we
win and that is a genius strategy right
make sure that everybody's invested in
your success it's also this is the
energy you want from a billionaire
unapologetic
let's not hide it somebody goes at
billionaires and you just go i'm just i
keep forgetting you're alive i keep
forgetting you're still alive he doesn't
say what he said hey these tax laws he
doesn't do that basil [ __ ] where you
like kind of skirt around you don't
address it
yeah he's the portnoy billionaires dog
that's what he is you're explaining
you're losing you know you just fire
back yeah just fire back we must demand
that the extremely wealthy pay their
fair share it's also a very reasonable
claim
yeah like extremely like neutral he
didn't even tweet him like he didn't
tweet at him but how could he point
in the tweet no he just said it he was
just like yo here's a neutral thing that
i'm sure no one will be mad at bernie's
more than that in tweets
he's gotten much wilder he's at you you
don't even need a sub like he will come
right at you yeah
but no no no elon doesn't have that say
what does anyone disagree with that elon
yeah dude the billionaires millionaires
disagree hard as [ __ ] eli about to be
like i'm not paying no more taxes man so
he just insults him elon is really out
here yeah
that [ __ ] is really out here and
i'll be honest like
if we're keeping it a buck
just started making money wait what do
you mean
tesla just started making money mm-hmm
like last quarter
profits or something like that like but
most of their profits comes from like
selling the um
they okay you have a certain amount of
like eco-friendly credits
and each car manufacturer needs to
have enough of these credits either
through their own fleet of cars or
through purchasing them from other car
manufacturers
right so since all the tesla's
are very green obviously because they're
not using no [ __ ] gas they got all
these credits to sell
so all their money i think like 70
percent of the money that they were
making was coming from these credits not
actually from the cars and for the first
time recently they started actually
making money so it's like
elon musk is beefing with jeff bezos
over like who's the number one guy and
it's like i bet i'm sure it takes
everything in bezos's [ __ ]
power to not looking and be like hey
little boy
little boy you just started making money
barely little boy
i print money little boy well how do you
know you just started making money so
you can look it up it's like i think
within the last few quarters uh tesla is
actually turning a pretty tesla based on
the car
not based on these credits that is a
government funded system
right whereas like if you sell paper
towels that's cash
this [ __ ] bezos prints cash but
amazon also wasn't profitable for a
while and by choice
wow they're just dumping money back
everybody expanding and like yeah yeah
the business itself is generating cash
yeah right and also amazon web services
was generating so much [ __ ] cash but
that's cash like [ __ ] just
paying you dollars
and then you have that money if you need
tesla is all speculative
like if another [ __ ] car company
comes out that's better than tesla at
electric cars they got electric car that
goes 2 000 miles and it doesn't look
like a [ __ ] honda accord
yo tesla's
game over yeah so they that's what i'm
saying like
and we just love elon so much that we're
like engaged in this beef and we're like
bezos is the bad guy [ __ ] bezos even
though basil's does way more for us
yeah bezos is out there delivering [ __ ]
to our [ __ ] house yeah but he's a
cook yeah yeah yeah yeah but he's out
there delivering [ __ ] to our house
within a day
and then he charges he delivers food to
our house delivers groceries so we don't
have to carry the [ __ ] groceries or a
girl don't have to carry the [ __ ]
groceries and then they start charging
9.99 for it and we're like how the [ __ ]
dare you i'm upset about this your car
don't go 30 miles without a charge done
i'm upset about this i still love that
[ __ ] because he's you can't even
drive the whole foods and pick up your
own [ __ ] groceries if you want it and
then you know what bezos is like i got
you yeah but you're still angry at basil
it's not healing basil's not funny
yeah it matters i mean it matters
bazel's not funny
it matters remember what you said when
you did that leo tweet you said what'd
you say this is the first time i've ever
liked bezos yo it's true he was kind of
funny investing funny dog i'm saying
that's [ __ ] funny man it [ __ ]
matters and elon understands it elon
knew that in order for him to have a
successful business he needed clout
he's the jake paul of automakers
okay he jake paul knew if i'm gonna be a
pay-per-view boxer i gotta build this
[ __ ] off of hype i don't gotta fight the
best boxers yeah this [ __ ]
wasn't fighting forward he wasn't
fighting gm
he's not really going up against them
right this is speculative he's selling
emission credits
the guy ain't a car maker profitably
he's an emission credit guy
but he kept doing it enough to where now
he's doing pay-per-view events and
that's what the [ __ ] elana's car they're
making now the cars are making money
fake it till you make it and tesla solar
is probably going to make a lot of money
when he has the solar panels for
people's houses houses right that's
probably going to make a lot of money
the guy
bought time with funny
bro being a celebrity we invested in him
we invested in him not the company
nobody knows the logistics of tesla you
don't know jack [ __ ] you didn't even
know they didn't make money until two
quarters ago but you know that you like
elon musk you know that he's a genius
and you're investing in elon musk and
you know what i did the same thing yep
people tell me he's a fraud all the time
he might be so he's funny do you think
he's a fraud i can't say you don't think
he's a fraud i don't think he's a fraud
but i can't disprove it kind of like
when you ask me why is bitcoin gonna
make money i can't i don't know i just
know i like elon musk and i trust him
because he's funny you trust your gut i
trust my gut my gut likes elon it's a
funny yo he'd be tickling my gut bruh
he'd be tickling
net worth in 2011 was like 20 bill
yeah
but that's based on stock evaluation he
is the
uh majority holder of tesla stock
paypal money
yeah
money i think to uh
start uh spacex something like that yeah
so he got this like crazy money
for
for paypal but that was like one of his
like first i guess big ventures and then
he almost went broke put his own money
up for spacex the final rocket before he
was about to go broke ends up going in
the air of course spacex explodes his
story is fascinating yeah like there's
an awesome motivational video you guys
can watch on youtube the one that's got
the gangster's paris paradise oh my god
you watch those oh dude i get geared up
on them like if i got i get hyped to do
something when he's about to cry a
little robot tears coming out
son you didn't watch this i'm gonna
watch there's so many of these types of
videos no no this is the one that's
because he gets dogged by all like the
real astronauts and like all light year
or whatever the [ __ ] puzzle is going
to work yes it's never going to work
i've been spending most of my life
living in and then elon's like yo i'm
going to do it
keep going with this [ __ ] that's what i
invested
in again yeah together we can go to
space and then that's what that's when
you come keep going
keep going i'm saying there's so many
things that rock is not the only thing
blasting off
before it was out here bro
oh dude it was so good i watch it
multiple times any time i want to get
charged up i want to watch it i'm going
to watch this yeah what's your
motivational porn just down syndrome
kids slapping their thighs you [ __ ]
creep
yeah what's this guy doing how do you
get motivated bezos videos dog yo i do
he's like yo we're never going to come
back i just knew we could provide a
service for people and we put to do it
in a more cost efficient way than
everybody then then that was our way to
win keep going what a [ __ ] video i'm
almost there
dude dave such a kind he said we're
going to live in space and that's lit